Eve is centuries old and she does not
seem at all jaded by life she lives
literally surrounded by books in Tangier
like a modern-day Paul Bowles she has
perspective and her books give her
company and with a little perspective
and good company I reckon you can hold
the jaded nurse at bay
and if you are as she is 3000 years old
she's a brooke terry druid by the way
you don't sweat the small the medium the
big stuff you just keep looking up and
waiting for the stars to do something
interesting at some point you know
that's a it's called perspective I
reckon because she lives in this world
of literature and prose in a relatively
isolated part of the world as far as the
West so she is not having to endure the
rigors of modernity which he eventually
has to do when she moves to Detroit for
a while so is Eve content well I take
issue with the idea that that tangi is
not modern I mean in many ways it's the
most modern place I can think of it's
like a kind of hot spot for any culture
from any planet you can imagine everyone
is passing through from every century
you can imagine I mean Paul Bowles and
William Burroughs are still there as far
as I'm concerned if not Christopher
Marlowe
it's all happening there so I would
suggest that in a way she's living a
more modern kind of vibe than he is he's
he's holding the world at bay but she's
in it you know she's she likes people
she's she's not put off them she's up
for it all and it's it's right what you
say she does adapt but she's got kind of
bent knees she's you know she's surfing
so by comparison Adam
has found himself in Detroit which as
you know is one of the roughest parts of
America he could not have found perhaps
a more terrifying patch of the of the 52
exist in it's a tough town a lot of
people have moved he lives in a really
kind of forsaken patch of the earth he
seems to be not at having as good a time
as as as Eva's with humanity but he's
very young a mere 500 years old he's got
a lot to learn and he's he's got so much
invested in putting up these walls and
being a command basically investing in
being in a bad mood give him a couple of
thousand years and he might get there
there's a moment where he dispatches in
his fixer to procure him a wooden tipped
bullet and we presume so he can kill
himself how could he leave Eve because
obviously they are lovers good friends
hardly anyone on the planet knows what
they know it's a great secret they have
together a great knowledge how could he
leave her first time I saw the bullet
was like really you really want to leave
this so as Eve because obviously you see
the bullet so there is this scene in the
film where did you feel betrayed by Adam
I mean it's hard to fathom but you know
he did he does leave the gun where she
can find it so you could say he's some
he's a little he's got the drama-queen
around the edges you know
and yeah he doesn't dissuade her from
coming to save him it's kind of the
routine I reckon well uh here's the
thing that I was trying to figure out
conventional couples or people who were
together if they are devoted to one
another they might have time away from
each other a day or in extraordinary
circumstances a week a month but if you
have presumably eternity to be together
time apart could be like a weekend to
myself could be for decades right my
question is why are two people two
vampires two immortals who are in love
with each other why are they living at
almost opposite ends of the world well
why wouldn't they they've got nothing to
lose and they're very different you know
there's something really beautiful about
the fact that these two people who
really really like each other
are so different from one another
they're I mean the I have to tell you if
you don't know this that the the first
kind of grain in this oyster for Jim was
Mark Twain's beautiful diaries of Adam
and Eve which are kind of fictional or
not Diaries of the original Adam and Eve
and they're so beautiful the way in
which this was the original grain was to
show a long long marriage between two
people who are so different from one
another he's this commotion stumping
around the garden saying weddings to
have got to name all these animals and
he's really really bad mood constantly
and she's this space cadet who just
appears from nowhere in fact out of his
sight
saying are the stars I want to put them
in my hair you know and she throws rocks
at them to try just largely shadow and
she wants to make rhinoceroses domestic
pets and
and all that good stuff and they love
each other forever they are completely
coming from two different angles and
they are devoted to one another forever
and I love that I love the fact that Jim
chose to place at the heart of this
story this like this endless interest
between these two complete aliens
because they are in love and when you
have eternity and you trust each other
you can just take your hands off it and
not fear that it's going to go astray
it's you're not gonna mess with one
another you're not going to try and edit
each other into some version of you
you're not it's not romance you know
come together in oneness and then the
end on the screen like some vampire
films it's it's about the long haul it's
about the long long life and being so
interested in somebody and going man
you're super weird but I really am
interested in you I'm gonna I'm gonna
watch you being weird to me and keep you
company so so basically it's a love
story
at its core to me when I saw it a few
days ago it just spoke of the permanence
and the strength of love because no
doubt over the centuries for for Adam
and for you thousands of years there's
nothing that you two haven't seen from
plague where food items were hard to
procure but you adapted and you survived
and you both end up being incredibly
articulate sensitive creatures I just
think surviving things is kind of good
for the soul you know keeping going and
managing to prevail and managing to
prevail in good company you know going
through things together that in itself
is quite a kick and probably probably
makes you closer
well mortals usually in a life there's
maybe one two three things that they
look back and go can't believe I got
through that you know car accident or
some awful thing but in your life you'd
be able to say well yeah Genghis Khan
he was a drag yeah and bubonic plague
wasn't cool the potato famine I mean
there's all these things you can
reference yeah we're barely got through
that and so the Nietzschean axiom of
what does not kill you makes you
stronger you and Marlowe and Adam all
seem to have wisdom to burn
they're pretty humane vampires I mean
they're super evolved they're as close
as Jim would like them to have been
vegetarian but you know that there is
close to vegetarian as they could be and
they're you know trying to keep rolling
and evolving and and trying to retain
some kind of compassion for human beings
who are testing the limits yeah it's
it's a tough moment and and Adam who has
outright contempt for Humanity they're
zombies I would expect that he would be
just become disgusted with actually
killing live humans for blood because he
it would remind him of what they do to
each other and he would find it
repellent where centuries before this is
kind of how you got fed and ultimately
you must revert back to it there's a
thing that happens over and over in the
film that I'm sure you've been asked
about a million times the blood has a
narcotic effect on the vampires it I
don't know really anything about heroin
but it looks like when someone takes
that takes the this the rope off the arm
and the the blood with the heroine hits
the body
there's the SAG all of you you take the
shot of blood and there's that euphoric
kind of loss of consciousness for a
moment and that's displayed several
times
well it's nourishment you know it does
feed them and it keeps them living which
can't be said of all opiates but it has
a good feeling for them and it's true
there all sorts of things that people do
privately you know when the the nights
are drawing in and by themselves that
make them kind of fall back against sure
cushions but they aren't
and they aren't you know some some of
those things are good for you and feed
you and some some of those things don't
necessarily yeah I mean that's all in
there I mean it's it could though be a
really really good bar chocolate